- Meeting new people can be intimidating.
Instead of worrying about
how to make yourself feel comfortable,
shift your attitude to focus
on making the people around
you feel comfortable.
(upbeat music)
If you're on your own at a party,
join groups of three or more.
They're typically more
open to a new person.
Good job!
When it's just two people,
an unexpected third can feel like a crowd.
Don't wait for people to approach you.
Approach them!
Smile warmly, stand up straight,
and make eye contact.
Good things come to those who initiate.
Here, have a beer.
Remember these words:
- So, how about you?
- Invite them to tell you about themselves
and to go in the direction
they're most excited to go in.
(needle scratching)
Well, this is awkward.
One easy remedy for an
awkward silence is food.
Recipes, diets, restaurants,
everyone has something to say about food.
Stand and smile on phone interviews.
This improves the quality of your voice
and will make you sound more confident.
Hello!
Wait three seconds before
answering questions.
It helps you process the question
and you won't seem rushed or nervous.
When standing in a circle of people,
open it up to allow a new person in.
You'll make a great
impression on that person
and on the other people in the circle.
- My mom plays ice hockey.
- Wow.
- When exiting a conversation,
interrupt yourself, not them.
Make it clear that you
enjoyed the conversation
and that you have a reason for leaving.
- But I have to go to work,
but it was great to meet you.
- Great meeting you!
- (chuckles) See ya.
- See ya.
- Hmm, nice guy.
- What a gentleman.
- Yeah.
- If I had a daughter, I
would let her date him.
(upbeat music)
- Like who's gonna keep the
sandwich shop in business?
- Oh my god, I was like
what are we gonna talk about
and sandwiches come flying out of nowhere.
(chomping)